Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie!
This is going to be my Flash Episode 6 video,
Enter Zoom.
So many easter eggs, so much fun Linda Park
stuff, so let's get going.
Just careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet.
There is a new round of the reverse flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video so here we go starting with
top five WTF quick dad burn so Jesse quick
on earth two finds out that her dad Harrison
wells of earth two created all the metahuman's
and it seems like he just doesn't want to
tell everyone about it because of hubris think
it might be his hubris that leaves the rise
of zoom like he keeps trying to place blame
on Jay Garrick like all he's nice not enough
of a hero but my Jesse always so quick figures
things out so she's just like okay I get it
your kind of it or Baghdad but I still love
you most of this gets tied up in Cisco trying
to buy on him which I think it's funny the
way they use that term did you viable me what
did you buy Boonmee Cisco go try to touch
them again it is the writer slowly humanizing
this big bag version of Harrison wells I about
the serial killer version would've been a
bigger jerk but on the number for earth two
Oliver Queen shout out so this is where they
going to flashpoint territory if you ever
saw the animated movie or read the comic Thomas
Wayne becomes Batman instead of Bruce because
Bruce died they do the Queen's gambit like
in the background on the news and it's like
a twist on that they do the Thomas Wayne thinks
so maybe green arrow of earth two is Robert
Queen that was just fine I will I would expect
to get more earnest to Easter eggs for characters
that we know on Earth one already just like
little jokes or things on the newscast like
what they did this green arrow think on the
number three though Doctor light training
montage best training montage ever been there
was so many funny moments how long you been
keeping these around without you have a hobby
I love this is go make cardboard cutouts of
team flash it just had them sitting around
the warehouse like how long it is existed
movies chow was so much fun playing Linda
Park trying to play Earth to Linda Park Doctor
light think it is a Tropic thunder territory
on the dude playing the dude pretending to
be the other dude and just for reference Earth
to Doctor light she only escaped because she
took her costume often was able to use her
powers that mean she's naked running around
somewhere so somewhere on earth one if you
keep her eyes peeled you might see naked Linda
Park mate maybe maybe on the DVD bonus features
the maybe that hit the cutting room floor
on the number two though fake Doctor light
versus Barry Allen so this is so much fun
it's like Linda performing as like she's performing
theater that I do it okay that I do it at
that time then bring it back little bit little
too much though too much that time when she
does take down Barry in Leeds and really close
are you okay used to locate like it's like
okay of course zoom is probably watching this
somehow which is the real question like obviously
zoom knew that that was gonna happen so he
waited for them to disperse and came in later
you like to use beta fish I like to use bait
to so close and super comedy like one of the
funniest episodes of the flash ever one of
the scariest episodes ever in my number one
WTF Barry versus zoom is actually a really
good fight for is short as it was it's kind
like what you hope to have seen with the reverse
flash and Barry last year but with they never
really got to like you never got to those
big prolonged fights because Barry wasn't
that good as the flash yet any minute as good
as he's gotten since last season he exists,
in the same power imbalance was zoom reverse
flash season one way better than Barry season
one zoom season to also a lot better than
Barry season two suite throws the lighting
back at them but Barry does kind of defeat
him was science for a brief moment like that
the terminal velocity fix but resume beating
Barry like parading around town like look
at your guide here he is no God your flash
is dead it's almost like he wants to rub the
world's nose in it he wants everyone to see
that he is the best it's it's almost like
the hubris of earth two Harrison wells we
know for sure is not zoom now like earth two
Harrison wells wasn't able to admit his mistake
look I caused this huge explosion created
all these many humans create all these problems
zoom wants everyone to acknowledge his greatness
is not enough the he is the fastest he wants
everyone to see him being the fastest just
something to think about when you're theory
crafting zoom just as he is ready to kill
Barry does Cisco's able to get on with the
serum and zoom runs away before it takes effect
with your temporary victory but the interesting
thing is that Barry as he wakes up cannot
feel his legs so I think what's can happen
is is working to see an episode where Barry
just is out of commission and next week is
the gorilla Grodd episode of the plug and
have to find a way to defeat Grodd without
Barry having his superspeed and just a reminder
episode eight is going to be the big arrow
crossover so episode in the flash will come
first they'll be the first part of the crossover
and be the Vandal Savage episode than the
second part of that will be arrow episode
eight like the next night so be like a two-hour
short movie for legends of tomorrow it'll
it'll completely set up was going on with
legends of tomorrow that's what this pictures
all about not notice the clubs that Barry
is wearing that obviously has something to
do with the plot of the episode that this
picture is from the second part of that the
Garo half so the real question is is very
good to get the use of his legs back at the
end of the Grodd episode order to get to get
it back during the crossover episode what
I meant to do is I'll talk a little bit more
about that Grodd episode when I post a trailer
video later in the week that there's so much
we can talk about that it's going to be kind
of like a King Kong episode with Caitlin snow
but let me know in the comments what what
you guys favorite moment from the episode
was a just watching Barry go up against zoom
like see all the crazy stuff zoom can do we've
only seen the beginning of his powers actually
Danielle Panabaker did an interview where
she was teasing that zoom has a bunch of abilities
that we haven't seen yet so I just expect
zoom to do something even more spectacular
in a future episode.
Probably the midseason crossover which is
the mother really awesome things about the
episode that didn't really fit into my top
five so you have Patty here on the outside
is one of the few people that doesn't know
anything about what's going on the team flash
and sheet she had that conversation with Joe
were he's like look I'm involved with this
yeah but I'm not dirty just give me couple
days trust me and that you have the marriages
like want to do something tonight he's like
I got I got a thing with Joe tonight see you
can see the wheels turning in her head like
she figures out that Barry is hiding something
from her but as far as I can tell Patty still
doesn't find out that she is the flash at
least through the midseason finale that's
gonna happen in episode nine or if the gonna
save that for the second half of the season
definitely not as long as they stretch the
Iris West reveal in season one I'd I think
they learned that lesson like that okay when
I gonna drag it out that long good Patty has
that funny moment were she's like I'm not
baby crazy in all I could think about was
Wally West and Linda Park's children that
but obviously like Barry and Patty are gonna
be having babies or anything like that but
anytime people talk about having babies with
the flash you just you think of Wally West's
children and then it was irises moment at
the end before zoom came along where she and
Linda were talking will for going to be on
team flash we better start going to CrossFit
or something like that let me know what you
guys think if Linda Park were to actually
like to formally join team flash and start
helping out solving crimes do you think that
she should keep the Doctor light name or she
should take something else because in the
comics usually just Linda Park there was kind
of that Gwen Stacy Green goblin moment with
Linda but I've always a that's marble so I
don't think that's what they were going for
it is the any time ago on holds a heroine
over a building and drops are you think of
green goblin Gwen Stacy now what can happen
next is is is a new Jessica Jones trailer
so I'll post that hopefully in the next like
6 to 12 hours probably be Wednesday morning
and I'll do and arrow penalty agents of shield
and then and pry gonna do Supergirl on Thursday
so I'm on track to do everything but I should
be posting updates on twitter and Facebook
there are links for that at the bottom the
description while you guys wait for everything
to post you can click here for the last Star
Wars Trailer I posted it was like a long Han
Solo and Rey Clip and you can click here for
my flash season 2 playlist thank you so much
for watching, everybody high five and I'll
see you guys tonight!